[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme le temps passe voici un an déjà
que la france a vu renaître sur ces
pièces de monnaie l'éffigie célèbre de
la semeuse cher à la belle époque
un an déjà qu'albert camus prix nobel de
littérature
l'un des leaders de la pensée française
a été emporté à la fleur de large
un an bientôt que fausta copie l'idole
des foules sportive le plus
extraordinaire coureurs que le cyclisme
est connu a disparu et c'est cette année
encore qu'une autre idole populaire
clark gable le héros de tant de films
qui fit rêver le monde entier est mort
figure populaire de l'année margaret la
princesse margaret dont les âmes
sensibles suivirent pas à pas les élans
et les tristesses s'est mariée avec un
photographe
les rênes et pousse encore des berges et
autres mariages retentissant le roi
baudouin a épousé le prince espagnol
dounia fabiola autre roman sentimental
qui a fait palpiter le coeur tendre et
aux états unis
non là ce n'est pas un mariage mais
presque la nation américaine s'est donné
un nouveau président entre et cover boy
le jeune et dynamique john kennedy
cette chronique mondaine ne fera tout de
même pas oublier les soubresauts d'un
monde saisit de convulsions aux îles
hawaii le volcan mena l'oat a fait
parler de lui
prélude à des éruptions plus grave au
chili en effet la terre a tremblé au
milieu des dégâts de toutes sortes
villes secouées immeubles détruits
ouvrages d'art démoli église bousculer
l'ampleur du désastre apparaissait plus
grande chaque jour la catastrophe avait
atteint des provinces entières et le nom
de valdivia est désormais dans toutes
les mémoires
et puis il y a eu agadir des morts par
milliers en 15 secondes de plus violents
séismes des deux derniers siècles à
rayer agadir de la carte et ce qui était
l'une des plus riantes ville marocaine
est soudain devenu un amas de ruines au
désastre de cette nature marc app les
âmes ajoutait leur misère leurs
tracasseries leur drame l'histoire de
l'ue 2 l'avion espion devenait pour
monsieur kotcheff le prétexte à la
rupture brutale de la conférence au
sommet sur laquelle le monde avait les
yeux fixés et qui avait suscité tant
d'espoirs
l'espoir maintenant semblait tourner le
dos et la guerre froide réapparaître
en extrême orient d'accord et bougeaient
manifestation sur manifestation à propos
d'élections présidentielles un peu et et
des morts des blessés et le successeur
de thin man really qui pang s'est donné
la mort avec tous les siens dans un
spectaculaire suicide collectif
le japon n'était pas en reste la
discussion passionnée du traité de
sécurité américano japonais à secouer
les habitudes parlementaire c'est dans
un vent d'émeutes que le président de
l'assemblée a pu en dépit des
obstructive ouvrir la séance de
ratification début mouvementé d'une
série dramatique car le sens de l'ex
premier ministre monsieur kishi frappé
de six coups de poignard n'était qu'un
prélude et l'attentât qui coûta la vie
au leader socialiste à anouma frappé de
deux coups de poignard en pleine réunion
électorale par un assassin de 17 ans
peut donner au monde l'idée d'un japon
traversé de courants furieux
[Musique]
l'afrique du sud donnait d'autres sujets
de préoccupation
l'aggravation des lois de ségrégation
suscitait un contre mouvement de la
population noire qui se terminait dans
le drame noir et blanc que
s'affrontaient le sang coulait et le
premier ministre le docteur verwaerde
partisans de la ségrégation était
victime d'un attentat
[Musique]
crise dramatique dont le dernier mot
n'est sans doute pas prononcé
[Musique]
soixante l'amérique difficulté fidel
castro de plus en plus engagée dans une
politique anti buée ça semble devenu le
champion de moscou dans les mers
américaine
et puis le congo depuis quinze jours de
juillet dernier le roi des belges
proclama l'indépendance d'un état dont
monsieur lumumba prenez la direction le
congo vit des heures aussi confuse que
tragique
dès les premiers jours l'indiscipliné
des troupes congolaises renversé
l'euphorie de l'indépendance tout neuf à
la mutinerie succès de l'anarchie puis
le désordre puis la violence elles ont
pu parler dans le monde entier du drame
congolais
les belges eux restaient sur place
connurent des jours d'angoissé et
nombreux furent ceux qui abandonnant
tous passèrent le fleuve pour trouver
refuge à brazzaville le nu bientôt se
trouve à charger d'une tâche délicate
remettre de l'ordre dans un chaos qui
s'aggravait chaque jour et que la
présence des casques bleus séparez eux
mêmes par des divergences d'opinion
n'était pas toujours de nature à
améliorer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la prise de pouvoir du colonel mobutu
style aux manoeuvres de l'est et
l'arrestation de monsieur lumumba n'ont
sans doute pas mis fin à cette situation
congolaise aux allures de poudrière
[Musique]
enfin l'algérie surexcitation des
esprits en janvier qui fait naître des
barricades au coeur d'alger une émeute
qui dégénère en révolte de la part des
éléments européens partisans d'une
algérie française des coups de feu des
morts
[Applaudissements]
seule la parole du président de gaulle
fait réfléchir les esprits troublé et
calme l'agitation les barricades s'ouvre
pour la reddition de la gallia
[Musique]
et la détermination de l'algérie
algérienne renouvelle l'agitation dans
alger les activistes s'oppose à la force
publique
et élément nouveau dans le problème les
masses musulmanes manifestent dans la
rue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la force publique tient tête
mais alger compte à nouveau ces maps
tout de même le monde cette année à
d'autres orientations plus rassurante
espérons le dans la lutte pour l'espace
les états unis ont marqué des points
avec les satellites quiros dont les
caméras prendront des images de la terre
à 700 km de distance et avec le
satellite espion bidasses chargé de
détecter dès leur départ les fusées
intercontinentales et aussi avec les
disques aux verts de toute qualité pour
lesquels semblent avoir été mises au
point de façon définitive la technique
de rattrapage en dessin
la taurus ils ont réussi à ramener au
sol les chaînes fléchettes et écureuils
après un tour dans le cosmos voyage de
l'homme dans les espaces sidero et
maintenant pour bientôt
pour la france et dans un autre domaine
est là en faisant éclater à reggane ses
premières bombes nucléaires poser sa
candidature au club des nations atomique
toutes ces victoires technique ne serait
rien sans la bonne volonté des hommes
sans les images de l'espoir humains que
nous donne par exemple la création de la
nouvelle capitale du brésil
brasilia la ville la plus extraordinaire
du monde sorti du désert comme d'un coup
de baguette magique la cité s'en passer
et le signe d'un monde où l'avenir à sa
place
[Musique]
d'autres capitales sont nés dans le
monde dans le décor désertique de
nouakchott capitale de 4000 habitants
émouvante dans sa pauvreté
la mauritanie a fêté son indépendance
comme l'avait fait avant elle 14 états
de l'ex afrique française signe encore
d'un ongle où l'avenir à sa place
place à are après de touggourt six
forages ont fait jaillir l'eau
emmagasinée à 1700 mètres sous terre
le sahara redeviendra-t-il à un grand
pays agricole signe d'avenir signe
d'espoir
et au moment où le sang coule est à
alger le général de gaulle continuant
son voyage en algérie
voyez à courir vers lui des milliers
d'hommes qui lui tendait les mains
n'est ce pas cela aussi un signe
d'avenir un signe d'espoir
[Applaudissements]
sinda venir des signes d'espoir encore
cette rencontre à rome des athlètes
venus de tous les coins du monde pour
les jeux olympiques les peuples peut-on
croire peuvent donc s'affronter sans
haine
si les mains peuvent s'étendre
aujourd'hui il faut faire que la paix du
ciel devienne demain la paix des hommes
[Musique]